no me puede ayudar a William vas antes
lo paran en busca de ayuda en el popular
barrio de chillogallo al sur de Quito es
el presidente de la Federación de
barrios una agrupación que busca
organizar a los ciudadanos ante la
inseguridad estamos tomando iniciativas
como colocar las alarmas comunitarias
según datos de la policía las muertes
violentas aumentaron en un 28% en la
ciudad de Quito en todo 2022 de la
desatención del gobierno también crece
la inseguridad parte de su trabajo
consiste además en reunir las demandas
de los vecinos Rosa María Vázquez vive
desde hace 30 años en el barrio
regresar pronto a casas cerrar bien las
puertas no no estamos estamos mal pero
no solo la falta de seguridad afecta a
los Ecuatorianos la desatención en salud
también los aqueja Gabriel orihuela es
el presidente de la asociación de
pacientes del Ecuador una ong que busca
ayudar en el acceso a medicamentos
quisiéramos no tener que hacerlo que el
sistema funcionara bien y que los
medicamentos se le entregaran a los
pacientes en la farmacias hospitalaria
qué es lo que debería suceder
orihuela atribuye la falta de
medicamentos a la corrupción y la mala
planificación del Estado tras el Kobe 19
muchas medicinas les llegan a través de
donaciones de médicos el médico
junta todo lo que reciben cierto tiempo
y nosotros vamos a recoger ahora tienden
a unos 1.200 pacientes por todo el país
una de ellas es Michelle realpe vive en
Quito y enferma de lupus desde hace más
de 20 años toma en torno a 10 pastillas
al día La pandemia de Kobe 19 golpeó a
su economía de clase media ahora
complementa sus ingresos elaborando
estas lámparas aquí me paso puedo
pasarme el día entero sin el apoyo de la
asociación comprar todos sus
medicamentos sería complicado yo cuando
tengo trato de no saturar la ayuda no y
le digo Gabriel y ahora sí Gabriel te
pido que me ayudes esta vez por favor
entre tanto seguirá centrada En esta
actividad que le hace olvidar su